I really want to start with a sincere
congratulations I'm sure everyone coming
through in the speed dating today has
said the exact same thing
um this project means a lot to a lot of
people and it also
um you guys wanted to honor Chadwick how
did you did you put almost more pressure
on yourself making this movie than you
have on your previous projects because
of everything that you know what I mean
I would say I put less pressure on
myself
uh making this film
you know losing Chadwick was such a real
thing it was devastating it was
discombobulating
it was so hard
his death really hit hard and especially
because
I experienced it in isolation as did
everyone else you know it was a tough
time in the world and then this was
added to our our plate and so when it
came time to figure out how we were
going to move forward with black panther
without him I couldn't even imagine how
it was going to happen Ryan walked me
through the story and I was just like so
relieved because the story
Embraces the loss you know and our story
is is that law serves as the springboard
from which we're telling the story it
explores grief and all its complexity
and how different people respond to
grief
um in in
a varied ways and so when it came time
to make this film I mean life is just
too short to be stressed out
you know like what is the pressure for I
was just so happy to get back to this to
honor Chadwick and to play for a living
I was counting my blessings every day
and so this was a it was it was light it
was it was light it was cathartic and I
I embraced the process and just went
with it Ryan does such a great job with
this material like he's so good I'm
curious what he's like on set when he's
directing you does he when he wants you
to adjust something in your performance
is it like a few words or does he pull
you aside and it's like full sentences
oh
yeah Ryan will come to you and like he
he likes to like
he bows a little bit and like pulls you
into like a huddle like like a sports
coach
and uh he'll he'll you go it's good it's
good and then he'd be like and then
he'll give you a note and the note will
usually be a very short sentence see he
didn't talk much he just gives you
enough and then he opens it up for you
to respond
uh yeah but I care so much about what
Ryan thinks so he always has to start
off with this is not bad
my last question for you uh you've
worked on many different projects what
shot was the toughest one you've had in
your career in terms of camera move or
emotional complexity what's the one that
was really the back you know the tough
one I
all the movies I've worked on WOW
[Music]
wow God well I did this movie in
Australia called little monsters and it
had music children animals I saw the
movie well and zombies and you could
imagine how tough it was to get all
those things to cooperate so I can't
remember one shot but I just remember
that movie was hard to make and like
sometimes we were shooting without the
children and I had to like sing to an
open space it was Wild on that note I
gotta go I'm just gonna say again
congratulations thank you movie's
fantastic thank you so much